notre CA du lundi avec Jacques et
Christiane bonsoir à vous deux bonsoir
Jacques bonsoir bonsoir ça va bien vous
êtes bien reposé
Jacques va commencer avec vous valide la
transition énergétique investissement à
bécancourt soutien-gouvernemental pour
GM pour Posco 150 millions prêtés par
Québec 150 millions prêtés par Ottawa
200 emplois sont prévus prévus qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de ces développements de
cette annonce la vallée de la transition
notamment globalement moi je trouve que
c'est une bonne nouvelle au sens où si
on veut positionner le Québec dans un
avenir quand même assez rapproché en
terme de transition énergétique on sait
tous et toutes le qu'on s'en va vers
plus d'utilisation de batterie
d'électricité tout bon alors je pense
que le gouvernement du Québec avait pas
belle choix de le faire si d'ailleurs
Québec n'avait rien fait on serait les
premiers à le reprocher bon maintenant
après ça c'est toujours le débattre 150
millions j'entendais monsieur le goût
dire quand on prête on s'assure qu'il y
a un retour sur l'investissement auprès
du ministre des Finances puis dans les
caves du Conseil du Trésor il faudrait
voir à quelle hauteur 200 emplois qui
seront créés mais moi ce que je trouve
surtout général la bonne nouvelle dedans
c'est qu'un plus joli souvent dit ici on
est une économie de richesse naturelle
où on va transformer ailleurs alors que
l'on nous dit il y a du lithium il y a
du graphite il y aura peut-être des
projets miniers là dans les prochaines
années mais qu'on commence à réfléchir à
faire autre chose que d'extraire de la
matière première la Transformer ailleurs
ça je pense une bonne nouvelle pour le
Québec Christiane en fait d'accord avec
Jacques je trouve aussi c'était bien
annoncé par le gouvernement on a intégré
le volet de l'innovation du fond de
recherche
l'écosystème puis il faut le dire le
retour de JM c'est une bonne nouvelle
j'aime beaucoup le partenariat qui est
avec Posco pour les gens qui connaissent
moins Posco c'est une filiale de
l'Empire ça a commencé comme daillou
industriel il y a des années alors du
Sud lister en bourse 19 milliards de
capitalisation ils veulent être le
numéro 1 dans les cascades ils ont déjà
trois trois
usines de cathode c'est une bonne
nouvelle aussi parce qu'on veut jamais
que les premiers à construire quelque
chose alors je pense que c'est la moitié
du pour la très milliardaire GM et la
très milliardaire Bosco vient des
gouvernement
jusqu'à quel point il faut investir
est-ce qu'on est parti dans une course à
la subvention absolue dès qu'un grand
groupe s'installe passe par le Québec
pour aller en Ontario pour aller aux
États-Unis moi je me rappelle quand j'ai
commencé le mouvement syndical chartrain
disait que c'était les entreprises qui
siphonnaient les fonds publics alors que
dans le fond des fonds publics fallait
les investir en s'entend l'éducation
puis auprès des communautés j'étais
assez d'accord avec ça très mais en même
temps historiquement de le mouvement
syndical on a longtemps demandé aussi au
gouvernement aux États d'intervenir pour
soutenir la création d'emplois le
maintien des emplois la création
d'emploi et le développement économique
on a même créé des branches financières
avec Fonds d'action puis avec le fond
je m'apprêtais même donc alors donc on
est certain on est capable on est
capable je pense de à la fois imaginer
un financement puis un support auprès
des entreprise mais c'est sûr que
ça va on va juste que ou et ça s'arrête
quand parce qu'il y en a d'autres qui
vont cogner à la porte aussi et vous le
mentionnez ce sont des entreprises qui
sont pas en culotte courte là donc il y
a pas mal d'argent chez JM il y en a pas
mal puis on a déjà vu juste finir
là-dessus de déjà vu aussi le
gouvernement du Québec financier c'était
Hyundai il y a quelques années puis
quatre ans après ça 1986 450 millions 50
millions de subventions des
gouvernements puis en 93
ça prend des garanties quelque part mais
si on regarde l'industrie aéronautique
je trouve que c'est un bon exemple quand
on a créé la grappe en aéronautique oui
on a donné des subventions des
bombardiers à des pratiques on a créé
une grappe moderne d'industrie qui sont
devenus des toutes des grandes
entreprises ou des grands fournisseurs
là je pense que ça se potentiel là puis
regardons les choses d'une façon assez
simple c'est certainement mieux à mon
avis d'investir dans les composantes que
d'investir dans les batteries parce que
l'Ontario pour avoir l'usine de
Volkswagen il y a 13 milliards de
subventions donc 1 milliard de la part
du gouvernement ontarien puis on sait
que vers 2030 il va avoir des nouvelles
batteries plus efficaces tout ça alors
est-ce que le 20 milliards
qu'est-ce qui en arrivera alors je pense
qu'on joue dans les bonnes les voir
aujourd'hui les journalistes associés de
mettre en contradiction le gouvernement
de la CAF avec le fédéral 650 millions
qu'un milliards on va entendre tout de
suite François Legault dans ce cas-là
puisque vous ouvrez la porte à ça voici
ce que François Legault a répondu à mon
collègue Francis laling Journal de
Montréal
pour que des selluliers s'installent au
Québec donc c'est tout ça qui est
discuté puis négocié actuellement donc
est-ce que le Québec est traité de façon
équitable selon vous est-ce que ça prend
des milliards le maire Joe Preston de
Saint-Omer c'est aux oiseaux
j'imagine est-ce que vous pensez que
Monsieur faisceau va réussir à avoir ces
milliards pour on laisse faire et puis
on va travailler fort pour que le Québec
soit traité de façon équitable avec
l'Ontario et en ce moment ce qu'il l'est
ben écoutez les discussions sont en
cours donc il est trop tôt pour répondre
à ma question
fais attention de pas se prononcer tout
de suite mais est-ce que le Québec est
traité de façon équitable Sainte-Musse
c'est là où il y a Volkswagen
disparaîtra pas de matin je me rappelle
sur ce plateau quand on a discute
justement de l'usine de boxwagen de
batterie on trouvait que le Québec
c'était peut-être passé battu mais
l'Ontario va être le chef de fil au
niveau de l'automobile y compris dans la
transition la question c'est est-ce
qu'une place pour le Québec et quelle
place le Québec occupe on a déjà eu JM à
Boisbriand on a puis les sous-traitants
au Québec ont déjà été dans la filière
de l'industrie automobile canadienne
mais le Québec dépensera pas l'Ontario
je crois pas ça on a besoin quand même
je pense d'une grille combien on veut
mettre au total on le fait c'est une
bonne question est-ce qu'on a un
milliard au total est-ce que si on
appuie 10 entreprises c'est peut-être le
meilleur investissement qu'avoir
qu'avoir appuyé un une entreprise qui
Volkswagen
en sachant aussi qu'il y aura
certainement d'autres demandes les
tarifs d'électricité l'appui à
formations en tout cas ça prend de
l'argent privé aussi nous a dit le
directeur général de la vallée de la
transition énergétique
je dirais que c'était un certain
équilibre à quelque part entre ce que le
gouvernement peut faire mais
inévitablement les industriels doivent
se commettre ils doivent se investir
dans une unité d'opération ils doivent
investir aussi dans les projets de
recherche et d'innovations pour venir
stimuler l'ensemble du économie dont
notre gouvernement est aussi un acteur
important
j'aimerais ça ajuster là-dessus il faut
jamais perdre de vue que quand on
développe dans une région après ça
l'état d'assumer la construction des
écoles déjà la directrice du 6 du Centre
du Québec disait tant de milliers de
personnes de plus sur le territoire donc
il faut que le système hospitalier soit
capable de l'assumer la crise du
logement pour pas la donner puis la
relation a été posée d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui c'est un enjeu et la
question de la main d'oeuvre c'est bien
d'avoir plusieurs sites je pense que
dans cette perspective là pour éviter
d'ailleurs à l'époque à Bromont quand il
y avait Hyundai roman avait mis 20
millions pour créer une infrastructure
qui réconcée
Trois-Rivières et puis Shawinigan ok
sujet sur la représentation des femmes
dans la haute direction on va aller voir
tout de suite les données les fans dans
les postes de cadres dans les ca on est
passé de 17,8 à 20,5% de 2016 à 2020 les
hautes de direction 19,6 à 23,7 et tous
les dirigeants donc 29 à
31,4%. ça monte Christiane ça monte
lentement bah écoutez ça fait moins d'un
pour cent d'amélioration par an à ce
rythme-là pour atteindre 40%, 40 %, là
parité des gens c'est l'objectif visé
c'est l'objectif que la France a atteint
dépassé l'Italie l'Angleterre l'Union
européenne mais pour atteindre cet
objectif-là ça va nous prendre un autre
26 ans alors imaginez toutes les femmes
qui vont passer leur tour ça avance
possible
c'est le fameux 60% d'entreprise où les
C&A sont que composés
60% des conseils d'administration au
Canada ne comptait que des hommes en
2000 60% alors ça c'est assez quand même
incroyable alors de deux choses ou bien
vous avez pleinement conscience que ça
prend davantage de femmes pour des
raisons qu'on n'a pas besoin de
d'expliquer ce soir c'est une évidence
ou bien ça prend peut-être des méthodes
coercitives ça des lois mais c'est pas
des femmes comme ça prend la diversité
des gens quand on a une table puis on a
des femmes et des hommes 40% des deux
côtés on a des meilleures pratiques de
gouvernance des meilleurs résultats
toutes les études vont des autres ben
oui alors donc on voudrait pas non plus
avoir une compagnon on aurait juste des
femmes au conseil et on veut avoir une
entité qui reflète comment changer cette
chose là ah ben moi je pense qu'on est
au Canada on a pris l'approche anglaise
les Anglais ont bien réussi de dire on
s'explique si on atteint pas les cimes
puis sont arrivés à 40% au Canada on a
pris la même approche ça a pas tellement
bien marché alors moi je suis en faveur
de l'approche européenne qui était
l'approche de la loi avoir des lois puis
dans plusieurs pays on ces obligations
des obligations sur cinq ans sur cinq
ans d'atteindre les résultats sinon il y
a des pénalités la rémunération des
administrateurs ça marche tellement bien
Géral quand on suspend la rémunération
tout le monde comprend ce château
à des entreprises moi j'ai aucun
problème d'accord
donc on est dans la zone paritaire oui
c'est à peu près 55 ans 55 45 ok très
intéressant merci Jacques merci beaucoup
merci Christiane merci bonne soirée pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI